quería preguntarle claramente si es el
jefe del Estado sí o no también el jefe
del fiscal general y en cualquier caso
hasta dónde llegan sus atribuciones
Rodrigo muy buenas noches para ti para
toda la vasta audiencia de France 24
para latinoamérica y el mundo en efecto
el presidente de Colombia El jefe de
estado Pero igualmente el jefe de
gobierno y también es Suprema autoridad
administrativa la Constitución
colombiana incluye esta triple
denominación al señor presidente de la
república la segunda pregunta sí se
tiene que responder de manera negativa
jefe de estado no lo hace jefe de las
ramas del poder público que integran la
organización Estatal es un tema
totalmente distinto la fiscalía general
de la nación pertenece a la rama
judicial de Colombia que es un poder
absoluto mente independiente del
Ejecutivo en este caso El Ejecutivo
nacional liderado por el señor
presidente de la república Así que las
declaraciones no pueden ser más
desafortunadas en un momento Donde antes
por el contrario se hace un llamado muy
respetuoso para que los poderes públicos
se unan y cumplan con el propósito de
actuar de manera cordial y armónica Como
así lo dicta nuestra Constitución
aclarado esto el fiscal acusó a Petro de
dictador por preguntarle sobre la
investigación contra Daniel Hernández
otro fiscal del país tiene Petro la
atribución para hacer esta pregunta y
Qué se sabe de esa investigación
Bueno también hay que hacer la
aclaración de que la intervención del
fiscal tampoco es que haya sido muy
afortunada de catalogar de dictador o
realizar la pregunta que que hizo
respecto a la investigación el señor
presidente de la república Incluso como
cualquier ciudadano colombiano tiene la
potestad de hacerse
hacerse preguntas o hacerle consultas en
este caso al órgano investigador sobre
asuntos de interés nacional más sobre
más Más aún el presidente de la
república que tiene dentro de su función
velar por la unidad nacional hay que
recordar que nuestra propia Constitución
También incluye que el señor presidente
símbolo de esa unidad nacional Entonces
nada se opone a que él también pueda
hacer esas preguntas pero de que ellos
sea catalogado ya en exceso como una
dictadura no Considero que sea lo más
adecuado y correcto creo que el lenguaje
que se está utilizando es poco asertivo
y sin duda está generando lo que tenemos
como una crisis institucional del más
alto nivel en nuestro país y que sin
duda no le hace bien a la
institucionalidad tanto de la rama
judicial como en este caso del ejecutivo
nacional por último Por supuesto que el
señor fiscal general tendría y no
solamente él sino todos los fiscales que
actúan de manera Autónoma Dentro de este
órgano de investigación y acusación en
Colombia que brindar las informaciones
cuando el señor presidente de la
república tenga sobre asuntos de interés
nacional pero reitero no es una escala
jerárquica no es el presidente le dicte
órdenes al Señor fiscal sino que como
ramas del poder público su llamado
siempre ha sido al actuar coordinado y
sobre todo armónico importante tener esa
expresión Dentro de este desafortunado
choque de poderes en nuestro país